we're learning former national security
adviser john bolton apparently tried to
raise the alarm over rudy giuliani's
involvement in Ukraine the New York
Times is reporting that Bolton wanted
White House lawyers to be alerted back
in July when he learned about efforts to
pressure the country Bolton's former
aide that's fiona hill testified
yesterday before house impeachment
investigators bolton reportedly called
Giuliani president Trump's personal
attorney this a hand-grenade Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with more on
that story hand-grenade very graphic
description Nancy what else do we know
well Fiona Hill testified for more than
nine hour scale and she said that John
Bolton instructed her to go to the chief
lawyer at the National Security Council
and report that there was an outside
Ukraine policy very unusual that
involved the acting White House chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney a red flag from John
Bolton who was the president's own
national security adviser according to
the New York Times
Fiona Hill told lawmakers that Bolton
was concerned about the goals Rudy
Giuliani Gordon Sandland and acting
White House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
were pursuing in Ukraine Bolton advised
her to tell White House lawyers I'm not
part of whatever drug deal Sandland and
Mulvaney are cooking up his metaphor may
have referred to this in september CBS
News reported that shortly before mr.
Trump's call with Ukraine's president
that call was perfect it couldn't have
been nicer mr. Trump instructed Mulvaney
to hold off on releasing millions in
military aid for Ukraine as Giuliani
Sandland and president Trump all
pressured Ukrainian leaders to
investigate a campaign rival Joe Biden
today lawmakers will interview Deputy
Assistant Secretary of State George Kent
Kent oversaw former US ambassador to
Ukraine Murray yovanovich who testified
last week Democrats believe Jovanovic
was removed to make way for someone more
willing to pursue the president's
personal campaign goals and we were
blocked by the Ambassador who eventually
got fired
emails from this spring can't describe
to the Giuliani led efforts to sully
yovanovich and send her home as a quote
fake news driven smear she was the
victim of propaganda conspiracy theory
and an organized political hit job on
her
some Republicans argue these closed-door
depositions are unfair to the president
even if you're not going to allow the
American public to watch it live release
the transcripts House Intelligence
Chairman Adam Schiff says he will
release the transcripts once these
depositions wrap up but that four
investigative reasons is important that
witnesses don't know what the other has
said separately CBS News has confirmed
that the Department of Justice is now
investigating Rudy Giuliani and whether
he violated foreign lobbying rules after
two of his Ukraine led associates were
arrested last week Tony it's a major
development there Nancy thank you very
much